All it took was one erroneous letter
to end what seemed like a legendary
"Jeopardy!" championship run in the making.
Some fans think Ben Chan got a raw deal.
There's a reason "Jeopardy!" has lasted as long
as it has. Plenty of viewers tune in to test
their own trivia knowledge. Others are invested
in the contestants, and there's no greater thrill
than watching someone win one episode after
the next to get a formidable streak going.
It's also tough to watch an impressive streak end,
especially when that loss comes with controversy.
That was the case for the May 23,
2023 episode, featuring Ben Chan,
a nine-day returning champion.
He was in the lead going into
Final Jeopardy, for which the category was
"Shakespeare's Characters." The clue was:
"Both of the names of these 2 lovers in a
Shakespeare play come from
Latin words for 'blessed.'"
The other two contestants incorrectly
wrote "Romeo and Juliet." The correct
response was Beatrice and Benedick from "Much
Ado About Nothing." Chan was largely correct,
but he misspelled "Benedick" as "Benedict."
According to "Jeopardy!" rules, that was enough
to label his answer as incorrect, and he ended
up losing the episode and his winning streak.
"Unfortunately, that is not correct. The
correct response: Beatrice and Benedick."
There have been plenty of embarrassing flubs
on "Jeopardy!" over the years, and Chan's was
relatively mild compared to those. It's obvious
he knew the answer even if he didn't know how
to spell "Benedick." Numerous people took to
Twitter to express their disdain over the ruling,
especially seeing how Chan is obviously a
smart guy who could've gone far on the show.
One viewer tweeted,
"Since when does being off by
one letter count in final jep?
There's no other character he could have meant."
Many people agreed in the comments,
and it brings to light an important
distinction with Final Jeopardy.
Throughout most of any given game,
contestants have to say their response
out loud, meaning it just needs to
sound correct. Final Jeopardy requires
spelling, which makes things trickier.
Another Twitter user argued
the ruling was unfair in
light of another contestant's response, writing,
"Lynn doesn't finish spelling 'Juliet' yet it's
ruled as a complete (albeit incorrect) response,
and Ben misspells Benedick by one letter
and is ruled incorrect. Clearly they knew
what he was going for and yet ended
his run on a terrible technicality."
Another claimed that Chan would've
been fine had it been a regular clue:
"The thing I hate about #Jeopardy is if
Ben had said that response he would have
got it correct, but writing it was wrong.
The inconsistency has always bugged me."
It may indeed seem like splitting hairs
to say "Benedict" is too far away from
"Benedick" to be accurate, but "Jeopardy!"
seems to be technically in the right on this
one. On the show's website, there's
a section on spelling, which states,
"Jeopardy! is not a spelling test – unless,
of course, the category requires it. Written
responses to the Final Jeopardy! clue
do not have to be spelled correctly,
but they must be phonetically correct and not add
or subtract any extraneous sounds or syllables."
"Benedict" is pronounced slightly differently
than "Benedick," so going by the guidelines,
Ben Chan's answer should be labeled
inaccurate. And he may have been ruled
incorrect if he said "Benedict" with an
audible "t" in a regular clue as well.
On Reddit, one viewer thought the ruling
was tough but ultimately fair, writing,
"Unfortunately as much as it looks harsh, it is
the correct call. I have to lean with the judges
on this one. I just wish [host] Mayim would have
demonstrated the difference of the two names a bit
more or explained why Ben's answer is wrong. Like
along the lines of 'Unfortunately the judges will
not accept it as it is pronounced differently[,]'
or exaggerated the pronunciation slightly."
"It's a very memorable miss,
right? So if you're going to go out on
a miss, go out on a memorable miss."
Based on the online outrage, it's obvious
Chan was a fan favorite, but at least he's not
walking away empty-handed. His nine consecutive
victories earned him $252,600 in winnings. Plus,
he'll have a chance to win even more
during the 2023 Tournament of Champions.